die industrie steht vor einer revolution
nahezu unbemerkt von der breiten
öffentlichkeit akt sich etwas in der
industriellen produktion geändert zum
ersten mal wird karbon in großem stil in
der serienproduktion in der
autoindustrie eingesetzt und das hat
konsequenzen für unsere zukunft carbon
hat unglaubliche eigenschaften warum die
unsere welt verändern werden jetzt in
kriegs und science fiction
hier im deutschen museum in münchen wird
einem zum ersten mal vor augen geführt
was für ein unglaubliches material
carbon eigentlich ist in der
sonderausstellung harter stoff kann man
noch bis zum 12
juli 2015 sogar selbst damit
experimentieren aber was macht carbon so
einzigartig angefangen hat alles auf
unserem kopf oder besser gesagt stoffe
wie karbon gibt es auch in der natur und
sind auch dort materialien mit ganz
besonderen eigenschaften unserer haare
zum beispiel wie carbon sind sie ein
polymer das heißt ein material das auf
sehr großen miteinander verketteten
molekülen besteht durch diese
besonderheit haben sie auch besondere
eigenschaften unserer are zum beispiel
sind extrem reißfest und stabil oder
zellulose zb pflanzenfasern sie
ermöglichen überhaupt erst die stabilen
strukturen von stengel nächsten oder
baumstämmen unglaublich viel was in der
natur stabil ist besteht aus polymeren
das hat sich die chemie zu nutze gemacht
und von der natur gelernt ein ergebnis
davon ist zum beispiel karbon grundstoff
für die herstellung ist erdöl aus dem
das polymer pole acrylnitril auch brn
genannt gewonnen wird
waren es erst mal ein polymer aus dem
kunststofffasern wie zb brilon
hergestellt werden und daraus werden
solche pulver oder kunst feld decken
gemacht für carbon werden diese fasern
allerdings noch gebacken das heißt zwei
stunden lang werden sie auf bis zu 300
grad erhitzt dadurch gehen die
makromoleküle noch fester verbindungen
ein und bilden so genannte leitern die
super stabil sind
aber es gibt noch mehr 800 bis 1500 grad
dabei würden die fasern normalerweise
verbrennen damit das nicht passiert wird
einfach stickstoff in den ofen gefüllt
da kann dann nichts mehr brennen nach
zwei minuten bei diesen hohen
temperaturen sind wie light land noch
stabiler geworden und die carbonfasern
haben nahezu wundersame eigenschaften
bekommen
carbon ist jetzt reiß fester als stahl
oder titan ein nur 2 mm dicker faden ist
mit menschlicher kraft nicht mehr zu
ziehen
im nächsten schritt wird karbon zur
nahezu eierlegenden wollmilchsau wenn
die fasern miteinander verwoben zu einem
gewebe und wird dieses gewebe wiederum
mit einem anderen polymer wie zb
epoxydharz getränkt das dann aushärtet
entsteht ein material das nahezu
unkaputtbar ist cfk
carbonfaserverstärkten grundstoff man
kann sich das wie bei beton vorstellen
beton an sich ist schon ziemlich stabil
lege ich aber stahlmatten hinein und
stabilisiere ihm damit verändern sich
seine eigenschaften dramatisch er wird
viel stabiler
genau so funktioniert das mit karbon
gewebe jetzt mit epoxidharz das ergebnis
ist ein umfasst stabiles und jetzt kommt
es sensationell leichtes material dieses
fahrrad kann ich mit einem finger heben
gigantisch ist das im flugzeug oder
raketen immer mehr teile werden damit
hergestellt womit die konstruktion
leichter und viel sparsamer werden also
weniger brennstoff wird verbraucht und
noch ein schritt ist man weiter gekommen
vor ein paar jahren war ich in der
technischen hochschule in aachen der
rwth aachen wo versucht wurde cfk in der
autoindustrie in der serienproduktion
einzusetzen bis dahin war das einfach
unmöglich viel zu viel handarbeit war
nötig doch hier hat jetzt eine weitere
revolution stattgefunden
der bmw i3 wird in serie aus karbon
hergestellt es funktioniert es ist schon
wahnsinnig wie schnell sich unsere welt
verändert und es geht immer schneller
was ansonsten alles noch für
bahnbrechende veränderung basieren
werden erfahrt ihr in unserer neuen
rubrik click to watch on mit cedric hier
geht es zum beispiel darum wie drohnen
unsere welt verändern werden den link
zur ausstellung findet ihr hier geht
unbedingt hin das deutsche museum kann
man eigentlich immer besuchen es gibt
immer was neues zu entdecken und was
wünscht ihr euch ausgebuht was soll in
zukunft aus cfk hergestellt werden
diskutiert es in den kommentaren die
besten ideen geben wir an die ingenieure
weiter ist es übrigens auch ein
interessanter beruf ist wohl dazu gibt
es auch hier in der ausstellung
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
ich bleib dran